نتواجد الان هنا في مخيم جباليه حيث قامت
طائرات الاحتلال باستهداف عدد من المنازل
والشوارع وايضا اطلاق النار على عدد كبير
من المواطنين في هذه المنطقه الاح يحاول
منع اي مواطن ان يتقدم هنا في هذا الشارع
كما نسمع المدفعيه في المكان هذا
الشارع الوحيد الذي يستطيع المواطن من
خلالها الذهاب الى منطقه جباليا البلد
قوات الاحتلال تقوم باطلاق عدد من قذائف
المدفعيه في هذا المكان ايضا تدمير عدد من
المنازل واطلاق النار على المواطنين بشكل
مباشر هنا في اخر هذا الشارع يوجد عدد من
الشهداء ومن المصابين لم تتمكن الطواقم
الطبيه حتى اللحظه من الوصول اليهم لخطوره
الامر واطلاق قذائف المدفعيه بشكل متواصل
على هذه المنطقه الاحتلال الان يحاول فرض
حصار ما بين مخيم جباليا وجباليا البلد
وزل هذه المنطقه تماما من خلال اطلاق
القذائف بشكل متواصل وتدمير عدد من
البنايات لا يستطيع احد الوصول الان لهذه
المنطقه بسبب اطلاق قذائف المدفعيه بكثافه
ايضا على جانب اخر الاشتباكات ما زالت
مستمره بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال في عده محاور هنا في شمال قطاع
غزه في الجهه الغربيه لجبال وايضا في
الجهه الشرقيه بالقرب من موقع الاداره
المدنيه وما زالت الاشتباكات مستمره حتى
هذه اللحظه ايضا هناك صعوبه في الوصول
للمصابين ايضا بعد توقف جميع مستشفيات
الشمال وتوقف جميع المراكز الطبيه الان لا
يتوفر اي نقطه طبيه في شمال قطاع غزه
لاستقبال اي مصاب هكذا هو المشهد الان في
شمال القطاع مع اشتداد الغارات هنا في هذه
المناطق انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه